okay so fair warning I'm going to talk
about the end of this movie a little bit
in this review so you have been warned
okay let's do this 2012 so I went into
this movie with no expectations scratch
that I went into this movie with
expectations but much to my surprise I
actually enjoyed half maybe two-thirds
of this movie 2012 is the best Roland
Emmerich movie out there which
absolutely doesn't say but that's
what it is I went into this movie I just
want to see the earth just get ripped in
half like a play-doh ball you know and
for the first half two-thirds of the
movie that's exactly what's happening
because you know it's funny people
always ask me why can't you just sit
back and enjoy a popcorn flick for being
a popcorn flick not all movies are
supposed to be deep just turn your brain
off and sit back and enjoy it and the
answer is because I hate wasted
potential I hate watching a movie that's
mindless like GI Joe when it could be so
much more than what they made it but for
this particular movie 2012 I just wanted
to see splosions I'm not gonna lie it's
kind of like fireworks we don't light
off fireworks on the fourth of July to
remember the fight for our freedom we
should but in the end we just let off
that Maties because they're awesome not
that I condone such dangerous things
like m-80s or anything like that and
five hundreds though that will
knock your fillings out yeah those are
awesome and that's what I wanted for
2012 a mindless popcorn flick in which
the earth gets blown up like a sloppy
joe with an m-80 inside it and like I
said for the first half of the movie it
was it was awesome destruction on every
level the coast breaking up subway
trains coming out of the side of cliffs
while assets no narrowly escapes a
fireball it was a good time as long as
you don't take physics and logic into
account so many times you'll be like how
did they get there already yeah they
should have bleeding eardrums right now
if they're not already hamburger but you
have not seen destruction like this
before
like ever it's almost funny how much
destructions just shot on the screen at
the same time it is as if someone sneeze
250 million dollars of special effects
right on the screen there is a part of
your brain that will enjoy that some of
the special effects were but there's so
much going on it's like the chaos gives
you a DD you don't even concentrate on
what happened two seconds ago you are in
the moment as for the characters they
were their characters in a disaster
movie characters just don't get more
useless one guy stands out though I did
not give a about John Cusack or his
family I just didn't care but the hit
man from serenity he was awesome he
plays one of the main scientists who
found scientific evidence for the 2012
apocalypse thing so he's cool
and all character-driven sentiment that
you care about in this movie will
involve him
the president's played by Danny Glover
aka Morgan Freeman light Morgan Freeman
was probably off doing another voiceover
for something else so we got Murtaugh
from lethal weapon but he did a good job
he played a really cool president which
is always funny that Hollywood always
comes up with the best presidents like
ever thought of every president in the
movies are like the coolest presidents
ever made it's almost like they think of
a real president and give him a spine
initiative and integrity and voila good
president but after the hour of
something minutes of the earth tearing
itself apart and shrugging off the whole
human race everyone gets to their
destination where the movie goes from
the movie 2012 to the movie Poseidon if
there is a half an hour that can be cut
from this movie for the sake of making
it just a two hour movie it'd be the
last half hour of this movie easily
everyone gets into their arks we're
sailing for land and apparently
everything is fine it's like Earth threw
a little hissy fit like in the day after
tomorrow and now it's over with I mean
the crust isn't moving apart anymore
it's just it's all fine now I mean I
would think go to land all you want it's
still going to break apart and kill you
but no I mean starting over in the world
2012 would be cake compared to the day
after tomorrow at least in 2012 they
have normal temperature so the movie
goes from the most epic the earth is
doomed CGI money shot ever made to
Poseidon and then the earth is fine so I
would say check out this movie at
matinee price but since I just found out
that Roland Emmerich wants to make two
independent state sequels film
back-to-back I'd say boycott this movie
all together because that's some stupid
but check it out a matinee price
the first two hours of it anyway then
you can just walk out and if you want to
see my take on the 2012 apocalypse
Theory check out my video title mm fall
at the end of the world is yeah
whatever
it's on my channel check it out